ya tant de squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve avec talgo et mika sur double
action est c'est le genre de jeu qu'on
adore le genre du jeu qui fait rire sur
lequel on s'amuse à plusieurs entre amis
c'est un jeu extrêmement fun 1 par
exemple on peut tuer tartine ex bien
comme ça à temps non parce que voilà
comme ça
voilà pourquoi au plus tard le 26 mai à
coups de crosse dans ma nuque quoi la
particularité si on peut faire des
glissades comme ça un peu comme la à la
piscine à aqualand notamment bon
maintenant ça suffit de parler je
voulais foncé asselborn
le père des renards mais je te montrer
comment faire la danse des canards
c'est la danse des canards me diallo nom
est mort
l'embellie netia dernier allait qu'il
explique moi dafoe club et là je sodi
joue les gars je vous trouve pas je suis
seul entre des cartons là c'est pas pour
les clac kouame et à me prendre un
paquet de chips dans là le petit coup
dans le dos par mika en fait je les
place comme un dauphin dont je devais
gagner mater toi mon gars à temps mais à
quel moment vous êtes tous les mecs au
salut ça va quoi non ok les gars on se
déplace que en glissant avec contrôler
clic droit at appris qu'hier au niveau
des noix de coco des testicules
on est bien là on se méfiait je suis
bloqué f&a mais c'est dangereux ce truc
tassé dans un parc pour enfants quoi
mais ils ont pas où tu joues bien mon
gars
mais julien j'arrivais point aussi au
point où ce juste à temps nicolas vial a
mis ko que tu me fais quoi
non mais là on vient bientôt au la taxe
au teint hâlé
oui genre qu'est ce qu'il ya là certains
biens ménages t'attendons je t'attends
et à supposer je suis posé je t'attends
je vis du football
tu fais quoi je m'engageais pas les
points en feu c'est rien ça c'est juste
mis des mains d'andré laur voilà sous le
chaud soleil mais terni jadida il était
super forme
ses toiles et ses incroyables et super
bien sûr mais la moto le mec qui me
tourner le dessus et ça vous viendrez
interviendra au luc a vous êtes tous les
gars moi je nettoie son avec mon costume
actuellement la discrétion
où était la discrétion
vous voulez quoi vous voulez quoi voulez
quoi mais [ __ ] mais tu as les ponts
mais j'aime pas les points en dehors
mais où tu vois de lormont gavia au plat
rien mais non soit tu es lo meka mais
mika tu fais quoi dans le coin non non
non kuhn un battant mais à quelqu'un par
ici mais oui et au temps peur chez moi
je t'ai pas venez à moi c'était une
danse russe quoi
coucou coucou au revoir ok merci et
gratuit c'est toi qui est venu me dire
bonjour oui car oui oui qu'est ce qu'il
ya hugo c'est moi je partais à tsahal
tué un pauvre mec qui cherchent un
serveur à lorsque soudainement et mika
mika retourne toi
battez l'engager
le tartam et je te mets 14 c'était la
maternelle toi non non le but il a gâché
mon plan machiavélique
aucun écart mais non américain abattu
était plus fort boum
on a quelques connards fausses bananes
tranquillement la chanson bad egg me
tâte et où c'est ça hop là dans tes
fesses viaméca hop là ça va quoi
or
la projection a dû toucher des couilles
en or quoi verra bien la vengeance et la
vengeance
le second tour de l'aide du combat
légendaire hugo c'est la battle amical
au regard ça gêne les gars j'annonce je
vais jouer au point auquel vous voulez
pas moyen regarde certains les gens
courageux ils arrivent derrière un autre
ennemi et se font tuer les gens
courageux
pourquoi maintenant non à la discrétion
ou tarte insalubres
c'est l'heure pour nous de tuer hugo
points ça va marcher comme ça maintenant
mais tu m'as mines j'avais pu suivre
j'avais vu au c'est stopper son
agression dans une petite ruelle son
handicap non non c'est pas des points ça
vient je tire des balles ils tuent avec
ses propres acquis nos bagages etc avec
jacky mon talent et akimbo ta gueule
aylwin une chute c'était bon hugo la fin
de la teneur et oui on regarde la
tartine ex qui va cependant une grenade
le dessus juste et je me rende mon dada
c'est comme ça ouais mais il vient juste
à temps mais c'est bien bien bien si tu
as des couilles viens viens c'est a des
couilles pourquoi t d que mon enfant
oh non mais tu ne meurs pas à tintin au
losc il a le style du backhaul carrément
sur la forme je vais dans le vide et en
fait non on est tous peut-être
c'est pas toi ô franchement je mets dans
le prochain exploit des jeux s'est pas
fait un truc
attends je fais je fais unique h mini
cars et dont anne on est sympa mais
c'est bien tombé dans le vide n'y avait
aucun problème
montrez vous les gars j'étais derrière
mais de se montrer et pas venir voir mes
fesses je n'ai pas mon cas tu viens bien
non louis ii fait ricaner
je refuse je te baise rire bien la voilà
tu vois c'est exactement ce que je
disais que je disais à mon tour de la
paix j'étais avec mes folies pour mai
qui verger défonce lui disais ça mérite
d'être clair promet qu'il a je défonce
bien chaud derrière comme ça je suis
caché je suis caché et vas-y je tombais
cette novlangue je vais dans le
checkpoint de manière non lui d'abord je
suis brésilien
je te défonce mon gars c'est marrant
parce que tu vas mourir certains thèmes
sont au rouge que je fais un grand écart
en l'air c'est l'heure de la vengeance
et pour vous chers abonnés vous abonner
watford et tu crois
personne ne sera déçu ici à 100 que je
tue yes tient le cadavre
quand tu vois tout excité parce que j'ai
violé
je savais et elle est revenue me kammer
me revient ah ouais t'es sûr fait froid
je suis sûr bien sauf si t'es un homme
outre os creuse au revoir non non jour
et toujours pas utiliser ce poney à tous
un bon gars et moi l'agencé sur cette
magnifique action ce qu'il fallait à un
moment que je fasse quelque chose de
beau parce que je me suis fait martelé
pendant toute la partie
j'espère si vous a plus c'est le cas
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à sauter
de toit en toit voilà ne fait surtout
pas ça des fois ya des petites surprises
des jeux comme ça que tu découvres et
qui sont vraiment marrant et fun en plus
il est gratuit
on s'en sort très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat monde pis
oh